Hi!
Herzlich willkommen zurück auf meinem Kanal.
Wir werden heute Kräuter pflanzen.
Egal ob das die Kräuter sind, die ich mir
jetzt hier ausgesucht habe oder vielleicht
auch ganz andere.
Ich zeige euch jetzt, wie ihr für jedes Kraut,
was in eurem Garten wachsen könnte, was ihr
vielleicht anbauen wollt, den richtigen Platz
bestimmt und eure Beete perfekt vorbereitet,
so dass ihr hoffentlich ganz bald ganz viele
leckere Kräuter zum Kochen und auch als Heilkräuter
in eurem Garten ernten könnt.
Los geht es.
Das hier ist das Beet, in das ich die Kräuter
pflanzen möchte und zwar allesamt, obwohl
die ganz unterschiedliche Ansprüche haben.
Direkt hier neben den Hühnern.
Hallo Pocahontas.
Und ich zeige euch jetzt, wie ich das so vorbereite
und so einteile, dass alle Kräuter trotzdem
glücklich sind.
Und zwar ist das ein Beet, das hier auf der
Seite den ganzen Tag quasi in der Sonne liegt.
Das ist ja für viele Kräuter super gut,
aber es gibt auch einige Kräuter, die lieber
im Schatten wachsen, und hier diese Seite
ist sehr, sehr schattig.
Die kriegt nur ein paar Sonnenstunden am Tag.
Das werde ich mir also zunutze machen.
Ich habe mir hier Kräuter ausgesucht für
euch, die extra ganz unterschiedliche Ansprüche
haben.
Und da kann man bei allen Kräutern drei Sachen
unterscheiden.
Es gibt Kräuter, die sehr gerne in der Sonne
wachsen, und es gibt Kräuter, die eher lieber
ein bisschen Schatten haben, nicht komplett
schattig, also ein paar Sonnenstunden am Tag
sollten die alle bekommen, aber es gibt welche,
die im Halbschatten sehr, sehr zufrieden sind.
Also das ist die erste Unterscheidungsgrundlage.
Dann gibt es Kräuter, die sehr gerne auf
einem sandigen und trockenen Boden wachsen.
Und es gibt Kräuter, die in unseren Kompostbeeten
super zurechtkommen und damit sehr, sehr glücklich
sind.
Wir legen unsere Beete, falls du das noch
nicht weißt, mit Kompost an.
Da kann ich euch mal ein Video hier oben verlinken
oder ihr kommt in meinen Minikurs, da zeige
ich euch nämlich, wie man diese Beete anlegt.
Der ist kostenlos.
Den Link packe ich euch gerne in die Videobeschreibung.
Also entweder die Kräuter mögen Sonne oder
Halbschatten oder sie mögen die Kompostbeete
oder auch normale Gartenerde oder eher sandigere
Beete.
Und die dritte Möglichkeit, Kräuter so ein
bisschen einzuteilen ist, ob sie es eher feucht
mögen oder eher trocken, das heißt, ob sie
eher ab und zu gegossen werden wollen.
Und wenn man sich alle Kräuter so anschaut,
dann kann man die in drei große Gruppen einteilen
und das hilft einem dann dabei, den perfekten
Standort für sie zu finden.
Das ist einmal Gruppe eins, die ganz Heißen.
Das sind diejenigen, die gerne in der Sonne
wachsen, in der prallen Sonne, die sandigen
Boden mögen und die kaum gegossen werden
wollen oder überhaupt nicht gegossen werden
wollen, weil sie es gerne sehr, sehr trocken
haben.
Das sind vor allem die mediterranen Kräuter.
Dann gibt es welche, die auch gerne in der
Sonne wachsen, aber auf Kompostbeeten sehr
gut wachsen und die keinen Sand eingearbeitet
wollen in ihre Beete.
Das sind die heißen Hungrigen.
Und dann gibt es welche, die es eher feucht
und halbschattig mögen, die Coolen.
So habe ich das mal für euch eingeteilt.
Und damit ihr jetzt, wenn ihr Kräuter pflanzen
wollt, genau wisst, in welche dieser Kategorien
eure Kräuter denn fallen, habe ich euch eine
Liste erstellt, wo wir alle Kräuter eingeordnet
haben, die uns eingefallen sind - ich hoffe,
wir haben an alle gedacht - in diese drei
Kategorien, denn wir werden jetzt hier unser
Beet in drei Abteilungen teilen und die Kräuter
so pflanzen, dass alle glücklich sind, obwohl
sie auf ein und demselben Beet wachsen.
Also hier ist wieder unser Beet und ich habe
euch ja schon erzählt, dass es in der Ecke
da schattig ist und deswegen ist das der perfekte
Ort für die Coolen.
Das ist die Ecke.
Hier wird es immer, immer sonniger und deswegen
kommt hier Gruppe zwei hin: Heiß und Hungrig.
Ich hoffe, man kann es lesen, tata.
Also hier unsere Zone drei, Zone zwei und
hier vorne in der prallen Sonne wollen die
ganz Heißen wachsen.
Und die stehen ja auf einen sandigen Boden,
deswegen werden wir jetzt erst mal Sand ranschaffen
und den ein bisschen dort einarbeiten, wo
unsere Kräuter später wachsen sollen.
So, kommen wir zu den Hauptdarstellern dieses
Streifens.
Hier in der Kategorie "So Hot", die ganz Heißen,
habe ich einmal einen Thymian und ein Bohnenkraut.
Die wollen es beide gerne sandig, sonnig und
trocken.
Dann haben wir bei den Heißen und Hungrigen
nur einen Kandidaten, das ist ein Majoran,
der kommt also gut in den Kompostbeeten hier
zurecht oder auch in normaler Gartenerde,
ohne dass man die mit Sand anreichert.
Und die ganz Coolen sind gleich drei, da haben
wir einen Kümmel, eine Schokominze, schmeckt
übrigens superlecker nach After Eight, richtig
geiles Zeug, und hier eine Hugominze.
Das sind meine Kandidaten.
Die werde ich jetzt hier schön am Weg entlang
pflanzen und so hat jeder genau den Standort,
der ihm gerecht wird.
Hier drüben ist es wirklich sehr schattig
und in die Richtung wird es dann immer sonniger.
Und bei den Dreien hier weiß ich, die freuen
sich mal ab und zu über ein bisschen Gießwasser.
Da hinten muss man dann, nachdem sie angewachsen
sind, überhaupt nicht mehr gießen.
Wenn ihr eure Kräuter pflanzt, dann natürlich
erst mal gründlich angießen.
Und ein Trick bei allen Pflanzen, die ihr
neu pflanzt, ist, dass ihr da rundherum so
eine Art Gießkragen macht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das auf der Kamera
so gut sehen kann, aber ich schichte immer
rund um die neu gepflanzten Pflanzen eine
Art Wall auf, so dass, wenn man die Pflanzen
gießt, das Gießwasser auch da bleibt, wo
es hin soll.
Und in den ersten Wochen müsst ihr die frisch
gepflanzten Kräuter natürlich immer noch
schön gießen, bis sie dann richtig angewachsen
sind.
So, fertig.
Das Ganze könnt ihr natürlich auch auf eine
Kräuterschnecke oder Kräuterspirale übertragen,
je nachdem ob eine Seite vielleicht mehr in
der Sonne liegt und eine mehr im Schatten.
Ansonsten wenn ihr nur ein sehr sonniges Beet
habt, dann sucht einfach dafür die sonnenliebenden
Kräuter aus und pflanzt die anderen in ein
anderes Beet.
Das könnt ihr sicher sehr gut auf euren Garten
übertragen.
In der Tabelle habe ich euch auch die richtigen
Pflanzabstände für alle Kräuter mit zusammengefasst.
Also ladet euch die gerne runter.
Der Link ist wie gesagt unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Da drüben findet ihr ein Video, in dem ich
euch zeige, wie ihr Kräuter durch Stecklinge
vermehren könnt und da unten ist auch noch
ein spannendes Video für euch.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns ja da wieder.
Ich freu mich auf jeden Fall auf nächste
Woche mit einem neuen Video.
Bis dann!
Macht es gut!